the Real Housewives of Atlanta go all
out in costume like Halloween you know
trick-or-treating with them I do we do
it all the full cast of our HOA gathered
for what appeared to be an epic
Halloween soiree attended season finale
party on Thursday night we're here to
look at all the factors everybody's
wearing wrong baby turn around let's
hear your tale kaya money's gonna tale
Kim Zolciak Biermann and her hubby Kroy
paid tribute to the late Hugh Hefner in
this couples costume while kandi Burruss
channeled penny wise from
friend of the cast of Marlo Hampton
brought her best BAPS Porsha Williams
supported this bloody bride ensemble
Sheree Whitfield and it season 10 newbie
Eva Marcille both came as Cleopatra and
Cynthia Bailey who nicknamed herself 50
cent King as 50 cent Kenya Moore who et
learned was disinvited from the all cast
trip this year we surfaced at the finale
party has a Victoria's Secret Angel then
there's nene leakes who might have a one
the night when she decided to poke fun
at her roach date feud with kim and her
daughter Brielle showing up as an
exterminator and her hubby Gregg a roach
it was real for sure
[Music]
you